ist natürlich auch ein persönlicher
Traum von mir ein bisschen weiter raus
zu schauen bisschen Licht in das Dunkle
zu tragen was ist da draußen noch habt
ihr euch diese Frage nicht auch schon
mal gestellt der Weltraum mit seinen
unendlichen Weiten so viel von dem wir
nichts wissen das kann einem doch
eigentlich gar nicht kalt lassen doch im
All geht es längst um viel mehr als zum
Träume
[Musik]
der ran auf die Rohstoffe macht auch vor
dem Mond nicht mehr halt schon 1969
suchten Astronauten nicht nur nach Sand
und Stau neben unzähligen ausgedienten
Satelliten umkreisen Weltraum Trümmer
die Erde diese verwandeln den Orbit
zunehmend in einen Schrottplatz
deutschland muss sich darauf einstellen
dass der Krieg der Zukunft auch mit
anderen Mitteln geführt wird denn im All
ist längst ein Wettkampf in Brandt ein
Kampf um Prestige Rohstoffe und
Sicherheit ein Kampf um Geld und Macht
und um die Frage wem gehört das All und
genau darum geht es in dieser Folge wir
fragen uns welche Regeln gelten
eigentlich da oben und vor welchen
Herausforderungen stehen wir beim großen
Menschheitstraum Raumfahrt hi ich bin
Lana grosse und das hier ist Kontext
ein kleiner Schritt für ein Menschen
ein Riesensprung für die Menschheit ich
gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus dass
ihr diesen Satz alle kennt und das
obwohl Neil Armstrong inform mehr als 50
Jahren gesagt hat aber der erste Mensch
auf dem Mond das war einfach ein
wahnsinns eignis was aber wahrscheinlich
die wenigsten wissen Grundlage für all
das was wir Menschen im also treiben ist
ein richtig gesehen der sogenannte
Weltraum Vertrag und der ist nicht nur
super schwammig sondern auch super alt
der weltraumvertrag von 1967 im Rahmen
der Vereinten Nationen spricht allgemein
davon man dürfe sich kein Territorium im
Weltraum und auf Himmelskörpern aneignen
die Vereinbarungen aus den 60er und 70er
Jahren des vergangenen Jahrhunderts
haben die Menge an Satelliten von heute
noch nicht berücksichtigen können denn
seitdem ist zwar technisch enorm viel
passiert rechtlich aber nicht und so
geht seit 56 Jahren ein Vertrag der im
Kern nicht verändert wurde mit krassen
Konsequenzen man muss schon sagen dass
der Weltraum so ein bisschen die im
Wilden Westen von Leuten in Anspruch
genommen worden ist ohne Regelung zum
Beispiel von denen die versuchen mit der
Faszination all sehr viel Geld zu
verdienen und zwar mit Reisen ins All
als erster Weltraumtourist gilt dennoch
Zeitung der Unternehmer ist 2001 die
erste Zivilperson die zur
Internationalen Raumstation ISS reist
pünktlich 11:37 Uhr Moskauer Zeit hebt
dieser US-Rakete ab vom cosmodrom in bei
nur ein Staat nach Maß die Ära des
Weltraumtourismus ist eröffnet 20 Jahre
später im Juli 2021 standen gleich zwei
Unternehmen mit Flügen ins All
den Anfang macht der britische
Milliardär Richard Branson Gründer von
Virgin gelecktik
ich war mal ein Kind das in die Sterne
geschaut und geträumt hat jetzt bin ich
ein Erwachsener in einem Raumschiff mit
anderen wundervollen Menschen und wir
schauen auf unsere schöne schöne Erde
herunter
nur wenige Tage später zieht Amazon
Gründer Jeff Bezos mit seinem
Unternehmen blue Origin nach
die Preise für einen Trip ins All legt
blue Origin individuell fest sie
variieren von 0 Dollar bis zu
zweistelligen Millionenbeträgen je nach
Fluggast vor allem die Milliardäre
Richard Branson und Jeff Bezos befinden
sich in einem kindischen Weltraum
Wettlauf beide waren im vergangenen Jahr
mit Raumschiffen ihrer privaten
Raumfahrtunternehmen selbst auf einem
spaßigen Kurztrip im All und diesen Spaß
will sich auch dieser Mann nicht
entgehen lassen Elon Musk mit seinem
Unternehmen SpaceX seine Raketen
beliefern seit 2021 die ISS mask
fantasiert zudem von einer Art
Massentourismus in die Schwerelosigkeit
und plant den Mars zu besiedeln eine
Fantasie die vor allem auf Kosten der
umweltgänge denn ein Weltraumflug
verbraucht den etwa so viel CO2 wie 150
Langstreckenflüge Hund ein echter
Weltraumtourismus würde ein bestehendes
weit größeres Problem noch verstärken
ansonsten hat es der es geschafft das
Universum ähnlich zu verschmutzen wie
den Planeten selbst
ausgebrannte Raketenstufen kaputte
Satelliten verlorene Schraubenzieher der
Orbit um die Erde ist ein einziger
Müllhaufen es gibt inzwischen etwa
20.000 Objekte die mit einer Größe von
mehr als 10 cm um die Erde Rasen hinzu
kommen 700.000 kleinere Objekte die
immer noch größer als 1 cm sind alle
sind aufgrund ihrer hohen
Geschwindigkeit äußerst gefährlich denn
ein nur 10 cm großer Splitter reicht
theoretisch aus und beispielsweise einen
ganzen Satelliten zu zerstören und der
würde dann auch wieder in tausende Teile
zerspringen eine fatale Kettenreaktion
dann würde relativ schnell klar dass wir
in einigen Jahrzehnten einige Regionen
im All unbrauchbar gemacht haben für die
Raumfahrt und das Problem bleibt nicht
einfach da oben mit der Zeit sinkt der
Weltraum Müll in niedrigere Umlaufbahnen
und tritt schließlich in unserer
Atmosphäre ein und
nicht alles verglüht durch die
Reibungshitze beim Wiedereintritt in die
Erdatmosphäre das bedeutet in der
Konsequenz Trümmerteile fallen
unkontrolliert auf die Erde oder müssen
kontrolliert zum Absturz gebracht werden
ein Riesenproblem das muss verhindert
werden indem man die Objekte nach dem
Betrieb passiv macht also alles was
Energie enthält von Bord entlässt
ExpertInnen fordern deshalb ein Abkommen
dass sowohl Hersteller in als auch
nutzer:innen die Verantwortung zwingt
und zwar vom Staat eines Objekts bis zu
dem Zeitpunkt an dem dieses wieder
zurückgeholt werden muss doch viele
Staaten und die müssten so ein Abkommen
ja unterzeichnen sehen das Problem ist
ja nicht oder anders gesagt rückholungen
sind sehr teuer stattdessen
konzentrieren sie sich eher auf andere
Sachen Bergbau auf dem Mond oder den
Asteroiden war schon immer ein Thema aus
Science-Fiction Erzählungen doch aus
Science Fiction könnte tatsächlich
Realität werden denn die Idee vom
Bergbau um alles einfach zu lukrativ
schätzungen gehen davon aus dass 30% der
erdnahen Asteroiden aus Metallen wie
Eisen Nickel Kobalt Gold oder Platin
bestehen allein ein Asteroid in der
Größe von Sylt soll aus Gold im Wert von
4 Billionen Euro bestehen ein
gigantisches Geschäft in diesem
Zusammenhang kam es 2019 zu einer
merkwürdigen Meldung Luxemburg und die
USA schlossen einen Vertrag über eine
enge Zusammenarbeit bei der
kommerziellen Nutzung des Weltraums und
nicht nur das die USA und Luxemburg
haben sogar Gesetze erlassen die im All
gewonnenen Rohstoffe zu ihrem Eigentum
erklären und damit zum Eigentum von dort
ansässigen Unternehmen die Frage ist nur
dürfen die das überhaupt
recht Problem nur ist wer kann das
sanktionieren es gibt keine Weltraum
Polizei eigentlich gilt das sogenannte
aneignungsverbot nach Artikel 2 des
weltraumvertrags darin steht das
Schürfen von Rohstoffen ist nur zum
Wohle der Menschheit erlaubt und nicht
zum Wohle von Unternehmen deswegen
fordern vor allem Industrieverbände eine
andere nationale Gesetzgebung der
Bundesverband der deutschen Industrie
kurz BDI er will einen Deutschen
rohstoffabbauvertrag tatsächlich findet
sich aber auch im Koalitionsvertrag der
Bundesregierung die Absicht ein
nationales weltraumgesetz auf den Weg zu
bringen um wie es dort heißt
investitions- und Rechtssicherheit für
nichtstaatliche Raumfahrtaktivitäten zu
schaffen fakt ist Rohstoffabbau fände in
einer rechtlichen Grauzone statt denn
egal was nationale Gesetze sagen ist
gilt der internationale weltraumvertrag
aber ist es überhaupt realistisch das
Unternehmen in naher Zukunft Rohstoffe
im All abbauen ich gehe aber davon aus
dass man in den nächsten 50 bis 100
Jahren dauern wird bis wir entsprechende
Technologien für den Abbau und die
Infrastruktur haben um diese Rohstoffe
auf die Erde zu transportieren und das
klingt doch so gar nicht mehr nach
Science Fiction sondern nach einer
echten Jagd nach Rohstoffen aber was
passiert eigentlich wenn es dabei zu
Auseinandersetzung kommt wenn das All
zum Austrag den Ort für Konflikte wird
wie vulnerabel unsere Technik da oben
ist hat nicht zuletzt der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine gezeigt
Krieg auch im cyberraum am ersten
Kriegstag fallen europaweit zehntausende
Modems des satellitenbetreibers weyerset
aus es ist eine russische Cyber-Attacke
denn Geopolitik findet längst auch im
und überall statt moderne Armeen sind
auf
kommunikationsaufklärungs- und
Navigationssatelliten angewiesen und
auch unsere zivile Infrastruktur wie
gps-dienste oder Bankensysteme hängt
davon ab Satelliten zu hacken oder zu
zerstören hat also großes
Schadenspotential und der Wettlauf um
die Vorherrschaft eine lange Geschichte
und die beginnt so
1957 schickt die Sowjetunion den ersten
Satelliten ins All Sputnik umkreist die
Erde knapp drei Monate lang und funkt
dabei Signale an die Welt dann verblüht
er in der Atmosphäre im Westen löst die
Sensation einen Schock aus
[Musik]
1957 die Welt ist geteilt in Ost und
West mitten im Kalten Krieg ein Jahr
später schießen die USA ihren ersten
Satelliten Explorer one hinterher eine
Rakete aus Hans will Alabama rettet den
Ruf der Supermacht USA
schon seit Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
bilden die USA militärisches Personal
speziell für den Weltraum aus 1982 wird
dann das Air Force space command
gegründet und wenig später folgt das
eine F15 feuert die antisatellitenwaffe
in den Weltraum und diese Assad Rakete
erfasst dann ihr Ziel vermittelts
eingebauter Wärmesensoren da dieses Ziel
ein ausrangierter Satellit ist wird
sozusagen erstmals im Weltraum scharf
geschossen Gegner betrachten deshalb das
Assad Programm als Startschuss für den
Sternenkrieg schlechthin dazu ist es
glücklicherweise nicht gekommen zu
Wahrheit gehört aber auch dass das unter
anderem daran liegt dass jeder Test von
Waffen eine Gefahr für alle Objekte im
All bedeutet auch für die eigenen erst
2007 also mehr als 30 Jahre später wird
erneut ein Satellit im Weltraum
abgeschossen diesmal von China in 800 km
Höhe haben sie einen ihrer veralteten
Wettersatelliten vom Boden aus mit einer
Rakete abgeschossen
ihr seht das Wettrüsten im All ist voll
im Gange und nehmen den USA Russland und
China sind mittlerweile auch andere
Länder wie Japan Indien und Nordkorea
daran beteiligt alle mit
unterschiedlichen Interessen was wir
schon beobachtet haben sind Annäherungen
ausländische Satelliten an unsere und da
kann man dann nur raten was sie machen
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß dass Sie
unsere Frequenzen Abhören dass Sie
unseren Funk Abhören wollen oder den den
Satelliten vielleicht vermessen um ihn
dann später stören zu können das war der
Leiter des weltraumkommandos der
Bundeswehr ja ihr habt richtig gehört
Deutschland hat ein weltraumkommando
seit etwa zwei Jahren bestehend aus rund
80 Mitarbeiterin für Deutschland sind
weltraumoperationen immer defensiv
Operationen deswegen stellt das neue
weltraumkommando eben mit seinen Mitteln
vor allen Dingen die friedliche Nutzung
des Weltraum
klingt ein bisschen allgemein sind aber
vor allem die Beobachtung der
bundeswehrsatelliten sollte es
tatsächlich zu einem physischen Angriff
kommen was und das muss ich an dieser
Stelle auch einmal ganz klar sagen
bisher nicht passiert ist falls es also
zu einem Angriff kommen sollte gäbe es
auch noch die NATO das
Verteidigungsbündnis erklärt den
Weltraum 2019 zum offiziellen
Operationsgebiet lässt aber eine
wichtige Frage offen was wäre eine
verhältnismäßige Reaktion auf einen
Angriff und da hat die NATO klar gemacht
auch Satelliten sind gewisse Maßen
territorial das heißt wenn ihr ihr
wussten ihr Chinesen unser dritten
angreift dann ist das eine Art Bündnis
weil dann schlagen wir zurück und das
hieße dann Krieg ums all aber alles
hypothetisch trotzdem betreiben
mittlerweile 70 Länder zivile und
militärische Operation im Weltall und
ihre Raumfahrt Budgets im Bereich
Verteidigung sind im vergangenen Jahr um
16 % auf 48 Milliarden Dollar gestiegen
das ist fast die Hälfte des gesamts was
wäre wenn ich die eigen ausgedienten
Satelliten abgeschossen werden sondern
fremde funktionierende das Ziel sind ja
was wäre dann im bis heute gültigen
weltraumvertrag steht dazu nichts er
verbietet zwar die Stationierung von
nuklear und Massenvernichtungswaffen
nicht aber ihre Detonation oder die
Stationierung anderer Waffen soweit so
lückenhaft es gibt noch keine Regeln wie
sich satellitenschama verhalten müssen
keine Verkehrsregeln keine
Sicherheitsregeln keine moralischen
Regeln und das könnte fatale Folgen
haben ExpertInnen waren davor dass wir
gerade die Fehler die wir bei den Ozean
gemacht haben im Orbit wiederholen
ungenügende Regeln haben zu Überfischung
Zerstörung von Lebensräumen und ihre
versiblen Verschmutzungen geführt und
das tut nun auch im All ich sehe da
nicht so den Unterschied ob es jetzt
kommerzielle Missionen sind oder
staatliche Missionen weil das muss man
auch wissen der Weltraum Schrott oder
die Weltraum Schrott verursachen ist
nicht reguliert also auch bei den
staatlichen
eine Aktionen und das ist ein großes
Problem und dem müsste sich auch ein
internationales Gremium mal wirklich
annehmen eine Reform des
weltraumvertrags ist also notwendig um
Akteurinnen stärker in die Pflicht zu
nehmen egal ob staatliche oder zunehmend
auch private egal ob beim Thema
Umweltschutz oder Sicherheit dazu gab es
auch immer wieder Vorstöße auf
nationaler Ebene von internationalen
Wissenschaftsorganisationen und auf
unebene aber alle ohne Erfolg der Grund
individuelle Interesse was denkt ihr
müsste der Weltraum besser reguliert
werden schreibt es mir gerne in die
Kommentare und abonniert auch gerne
unseren Kanal wenn ihr noch mehr von
Kontext sehen wollt schaut euch gerne
diese Folge an wo es um den schlechten
Mobilfunk in Deutschland geht und wenn
Ihr noch mehr über das Weltall wissen
wollt empfehle ich euch dieses Video